thank you
uh we're gonna play the Peter King game
Peter King football morning in America
columnist and uh a frequent guest on
this show and your whole life is a
fantasy camp it has been really is I've
been very lucky yeah you get to see you
get to see me in shorts today I know
nice walk out in Scottsdale well America
gets to see him as well sorry America
sorry uh P we're gonna do a Peter King
game yeah this is we are a
thought-provoking question for Peter
King which he's never been asked I think
okay we're gonna bet on his answer Peter
I I know you're a lifelong Red Sox fan
right yeah there's all also had a one of
the great uh journalism careers Sports
11 careers of all time if you can have a
do-over and you can have your career in
Media or you could play 10 years for the
Red Sox and hit 275 and be kind of a New
England Legend not a Hall of Famer but a
good Red Sox career which would you take
oh we're betting on the answer go to bed
oh okay
to me it's obvious yeah
to me what it's obvious what you're
going to play baseball
well what does everybody say
Paulie
yeah baseball
Sweden baseball yeah protein coach I'm
ready to play yeah
so when I was that's a good one troy
O'Leary or or well what about Mike
Greenwell well no well you can't beat my
Greenwell well I don't want to be a
politician isn't that what he is now in
Florida I think okay here's the thing
Dan I said when I was in high school
that I wanted to play left field after
Carl these streams okay at Fenway Park I
said if I can't do that then I'd like to
write about Carly astromski and I don't
think I ever really did I actually did
interview him once but basically uh I
did the second best thing that I could
do with my life but would you have
rather covered baseball I know that
that's a love of yours but I'm really
like you know why I never covered
baseball because I was the backup beat
guy at the Cincinnati Enquirer on the
Cincinnati Reds from 80 to 83. I loved
it absolutely loved it one time shag uh
balls for Johnny Bench Dwayne Walker and
Paul householder at Bush state Stadium
at 10 o'clock in the morning me and Rich
Gail you know who through batting
practice that day Joe nux Hall yeah he
did it all the time I mean it was just a
phenomenal experience so I love doing
that the problem is the four people by
the time I got to the inquiry the four
people who preceded me on the beat all
were divorced I was newly married we
were going to have a family and I just
said I don't think that's the life for
me so football back end and I've loved
it but it takes you you're on the road a
lot or at least you used to be you used
to be on the road a lot more than I am
now I half the Sundays during the season
in the postseason I'm sitting at home in
Brooklyn just watching the games and
talking to people on the phone but when
you're covering the game you know what
what do you focus on for your column
each morning or Monday morning that you
wouldn't have focused on maybe you you
know 10 years ago I never know until the
games happen you know and that's the
thing like on Sunday at this game
there's a couple of things that really
interest me Chris Jones in the matchup
against the best offensive line that we
have seen in years I mean if you think
how great this Eagles offensive line is
you know in the playoffs so far they've
faced two excellent defensive fronts the
Giants and the 49ers and they have not
allowed a a sack or a quarterback hit in
eight quarters off of those two very
good defensive fronts and you know so
what is Chris Jones going to do and I'm
also going to be watching how is Steve
spagnolo going to scheme to so that he
can imitate what he did 15 years ago
Giants against Patriots when he showed
Tom Brady a bunch of stuff he never saw
before and the Giants ended up with one
of the big upsets in Super Bowl history
so those are the things but I always
think of four or five things that I'm
going to monitor before a game sometimes
they work out sometimes they don't
what's at stake for Mahomes and maybe at
stake is not a fair description but
what's on the line for him I you know
look Tom Brady played his third Super
Bowl by the time he was 27.
or at 27. Patrick Mahomes is playing his
third Super Bowl at 27. now being one
and two in Super Bowls is not the same
as being 3-0 obviously but the way I
look at it when Tom Brady left football
you know the other day we think for good
he also left his will you know who's got
the strongest will right now among the
1696 players in the NFL I would argue
Mahomes I thought what he did uh in the
AFC Championship game was seriously
fantastic you know historically you know
and and you know in playing with a high
ankle sprain and and being so good
overall and I I just think Dan he's
going to have so many chances with Andy
Reid as his coach who's going to coach
him for a while longer who knows how
much longer with Brett Veach as the GM
you know stealing Kadarius Tony during
the season you know they have got it
figured out right now and so I'm not
sure that no matter what happens to
Mahomes that we're going to look back
you know 15 years from now and just say
geez that was his last chance I don't
see this as a Merino type game for uh
Patrick Mahomes I know we're always
looking for the next franchise
quarterback but I wonder if there's a
team or teams that will look at this and
go we look at this in five-year Windows
yeah that we have that contract and we
can make everybody around that
quarterback better
uh or then you don't have to go into
that big contract there can you see
teams that would adapt that philosophy
or have adapt that adapted that
philosophy well I think that's a little
bit of a myth that that so many people
think boy you got to get great while
your quarterback is on his first
contract I mean Tom Brady was in 10
super bowls and only in two of them was
he on his first contract I I just but he
deferred money well not only did he
defer money but you know he basically
told the Patriots in 2005 as long as you
assure me that you're going to spend to
the cap every year I don't have to be
the pig at the trough and make the most
money of any quarterback now that's not
a popular View and I don't blame anybody
for trying to make as much as they can
but the fact is if you push to make as
much money as you can look at my homes
in the first three years of his new deal
he's allowing Brett Veach and Andy Reid
to go out by having smaller cab numbers
he's allowing them to go out and to
build a team I'm sure Jalen hurts is
going to do the exact same thing why
wouldn't he don't you want to win yeah
and so and Jay Jalen hurts has a lot of
Brady and Mahomes in him I think he's an
utterly selfless you know assassin type
guy when when it's hard to do
he's Peter King his column football
morning in America also contributor to
football night America you got all the
day Parts covered football morning
football night in America now your
afternoon she got to come up with
something there I'll try to think of
something uh I saw you on Pardon The
Interruption last night and you had some
fun with Tony and Mike when you're
talking about Aaron Rodgers going into
his oh dark dark place here I just you
know does Aaron Rodgers ever do anything
just normal no no I I mean you know but
Dan I'll tell you this
I lived it I don't cover it nearly the
way I used to but I lived it 15 years
ago when Brett Favre I was washing my
dog in the driveway literally in my home
in Upper Montclair New Jersey the phone
rang I looked down it was farv and he
basically said I I'm thinking about
coming out of retirement blah blah blah
it was May of 2008 and he had retired
because Ted Thompson and Mike McCarthy
said to him listen we got to have a
commitment you got to be with us in the
off season a little bit more than you
have blah blah blah or else you know we
want to play this kid so he decided to
retire it reminds me so much of this all
the way to Brett Favre ending up with
the New York Jets you know Aaron Rodgers
who was 24 at the time took the job
Jordan love who's 24 now could take the
job and for all those who say that oh my
God Jordan love he can't do it just go
back and read Bob again in the Milwaukee
Journal Sentinel in 2007 and 2008
believe me there was no sure thing that
Aaron Rodgers was going to be Aaron
Rodgers you know yeah I I just wonder
though like you get addicted to
attention and I don't know if Aaron just
he loves the attention but then he sort
of scold you for focusing he repels it
at times yeah so I'm trying to figure
out what his end game is here instead of
just doing something yeah without
telling us he's doing something I mean I
don't have to know all of his details
right right right but he's going to go
into a dark place for four days and then
come out and then he's going to make his
his decision yeah I I guess that's what
he's going to do and you know all power
to him he's earned the right to be able
to take as much time really as he wants
I would think up to around the first
week of March because then the Packers
have to make their plans yeah if he's
not gonna play and look they I don't
know what they're going to do all I do
know is that when Adam schefter comes on
and says hey it's looking pretty
promising that there could be a trade
here he knows things
and so that's why I have basically
thought
you know this guy's probably going to be
traded I don't know if he will but we'll
see the one thing I would say Dan is
that I I wonder if you're the New York
Jets right now okay and you'd have to
pay him a boatload of money this year
however they would work out the
financial details
you have to ask yourself if we're going
to give a one plus something for Aaron
Rodgers don't we want to be absolutely
sure that he's going to commit to us
absolute minimum for two years
you know you don't want to have a guy
who is going to be one and done you know
the way farv was with the Jets in 2008
so I think that's the biggest issue for
any team that's going to trade I have no
idea if it'll be the Jets or if it would
be the Jets if he would be available but
somebody has to make sure that he's not
just going to be one of them yeah I'd
hate to do that one and then he go you
know I'm gonna go to a dark place again
and I'm going to find out if I like I I
don't want to would you go into the dark
place with Aaron Rodgers as a journalist
I don't think oh well that really might
be fun would you do Ayahuasca no I would
not I wouldn't no no not again your days
in Ohio University I don't know I read
about it on Wikipedia media and I said
you know that really not be might not be
for me
the Miami situation I find interesting
because you know two are just getting
out of concussion protocol and you're
gonna have to commit to him but can you
commit to him long term
uh do you really have to commit to him
this year you don't have to you don't
have to and I think it would be
ill-advised to guarantee him 150 million
or whatever when
you're really not sure and you know
let's be fair I would say this to and or
his agents you know we got to be fair
about this if in week eight this year
you have two more concussions you know
by week eight you know we can't be
responsible for owing you money for the
next millennium you know whatever I'm
exaggerating obviously but I do think I
think Mike McDaniel absolutely likes and
wants to to be the quarterback but I
also think that you've got to be
pragmatic about it
yeah I just wonder that you know the
Lamar Jackson situation in Baltimore it
just it felt weird for about 18 months
for me where it wasn't like and then
then you throw in the DeSean Watson deal
yeah I'm sure that the owner probably
railed against the Browns for uh yeah
DeSean Watson that deal and then you
know Steve's can't give his quarterback
that deal after railing against the
Browns for doing it I mean whatever the
previous deals were whatever precedent
is here's my only question to people who
keep saying you got to pay Lamar got to
pay Lamar I would want to pay Lamar too
however
you've got to be a little bit realistic
about this Lamar Jackson in the last two
years has missed 34 of the Ravens
playing time
and you know you can say whatever you
want well freak injuries whatever here's
my question would you pay Jimmy
Garoppolo now and I realize Lamar
Jackson's a lot better than Garoppolo
but when a guy starts to show that he's
going to get hurt more than once you
have to start believing what you're
seeing and so I would want Lamar Jackson
if I were Eric DeCosta Steve bashati
John Harbaugh to be the quarterback of
my team no question about it but you've
got to be a little bit realistic about
the money you can't just oh pay the guy
pay him what you know what you can't
just exist in a vacuum like that well I
wonder you know you look at Cam Newton
after age 27 yeah he was never the same
yeah and people I'm sure were like you
got to pay cam use your franchise
quarterback well yeah at a certain
amount of time I look at Lamar and go
okay we beat him up by his playing style
now we don't want to pay him because
he's all beat up because of his playing
style I would franchise him you may not
like it but I would franchise them too
with the Lesser franchise tags so that
if somebody pays them a jillion dollars
and you don't want to pay them you get a
one plus yeah you might get two ones it
says you get two ones but the teams can
negotiate and I I would then if I were
the Ravens who I'm sure have very
quietly scouted quarterbacks in this
draft very well and I wonder if they say
man this Anthony Richardson pretty good
or whatever I but I have no idea what
they're going to do I definitely do know
that they would like this to be solved
and they'd like him to be their
quarterback for a while but you know
we'll see when do you make your Super
Bowl prediction I don't I mean I've
already said that I think the Eagles are
probably going to win but I just anytime
Patrick Mahomes is in a game
no one it doesn't matter if he's playing
some combination of the Lombardi Packers
and the Walsh 49ers I mean Patrick
Mahomes can win any game he plays yeah
he's graduated into that I'd never bet
against Tom Brady yeah that's right yeah
I mean he is he's the one player where
you go in but it's Patrick Mahomes yeah
uh Pete thank you again okay Dan thanks
a lot for all you're inviting me yes all
your controversy spot football morning
in America columnist and football night
in America